let's move to the riot story itself um
you know obviously publicly traded
companies there's some things you can
talk about some things you can't uh but
this was a
company in the public markets that uh
wasn't doing so hot maybe is a fair way
to put it and
it's an incredible turnaround story and
so maybe just start with like at what
point do you get pulled into riot and is
it even in the bitcoin mining business
at that point or is it doing something
else sure yeah so i was you know i
continued to play poker through this
whole bitcoin journey but eventually
the the i was so captivated by bitcoin i
couldn't focus on poker anymore i just
wanted to study and follow bitcoin
full-time so you know it's not like the
nba you don't announce retirement from
professional poker but you just kind of
stop playing one day
uh and i just you know i had no
aspirations of working in the industry
whatsoever i just wanted to
make bitcoin my life and just did more
software engineering more mining stuff
like that on my own and eventually i got
the opportunity to join the advisory
board of riot when it um i guess you
could say launch at the end of 2017.
they were a reverse merger of an
existing kind of publicly traded shell
that uh prior business hadn't been
successful and you know at the time riot
was trying to meet a need of giving
uh
public investors exposure to the bitcoin
blockchain
space
very early on riot was involved in
bitcoin mining but it was doing a number
of other things as well there was like
you know a little bit of litecoin mining
uh rye was looking at launching an
exchange was looking to um you know make
a mining pool had some strategic
investments in the space it was involved
in the space but kind of spread out all
over so i was on the advisory board and
then uh i was asked to join the board of
directors and you know kind of funny i'm
like hey i've
been a professional poker player for the
past you know 13 years like i don't know
what it what entails being on the uh
board of directors of a public company
and they said you know don't worry about
it it's you know we're looking for
bitcoin expertise uh you'll you're limit
everything else as you go along which
was true you know i dove in to you know
figure out everything that i i needed to
know to be successful at that job but
immediately after that was the end of
the 2017 bull market start of the 2018
bear market caused a massive decline in
the price of bitcoin and thus very
correlated riot stock and you know
especially as a public company that
brings all sorts of other problems so
you don't learn better than through
adversity
okay hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time